Mama June's daughter Anna chickadee
Cardwell has been diagnosed with cancer
TMZ reports the 28 year old reality star
was reportedly diagnosed with stage four
adrenal carcinoma in January DMZ says
chickadee initially complained about
stomach aches and after a series of
tests cancer was found in her liver
kidney and lung according to the report
chickadee underwent her first round of
chemotherapy last month and lost her
hair as a result now TMZ says doctors
are waiting to see how she reacts to the
treatment before moving forward but her
family is very hopeful she'll pull
through but chickadees Health Battle is
just the latest hardship for the reality
star the 10 years he served in prison
was that because of the allegations you
made or was it because of the allegation
to someone else the allegations I made
so he went to prison because of what
happened because you said he molested
you yes back in 2014 Anna spoke
exclusively to E.T about her claims that
she was molested by her mom Mama June's
ex Mark McDaniel when she was eight
years old Mama never say any of it you
know there was time the mom was there
and he you know gave me that look and
you know you know so every now and then
touch my leg and Mama would ever see it
you know mama was either turn the other
other cheek or in the kitchen or
something like that but Mama never seen
that he was that bold to do things to
you when your mother was there yeah and
the main stuff that happened was
whenever mama was at work did he tell
you not to tell hey tell me not to tell
anybody don't call the cops don't do
anything like that but it appears Anna
who has two children 10 year olds
Caitlyn and seven-year-olds Kylie has
found healing and love with her
boyfriend Eldridge who is often featured
on her social media chickadee took a
break from Instagram last year her most
recent post was in July 2022 and while
she hasn't addressed the reports of Her
diagnosis she did return to the gram
this week sharing a selfie alongside a
caption that read in part your girl is
back
foreign